let's make sure we are ready for some
love for stainless if you were here
on sunday i talked about i showed
another amazing game of stains which was
very similar to this stains anderson
and i think it would be a great idea for
you guys to also take a look at that
if there you get a chance uh that one
was on twitch yeah i was impersonating
talia it was amazing
i think i could make a good italian
while talia was slaying dragons
and hello
yeah he hasn't been sick in years so i'm
a little
uncertain how to handle this should i
just let it pass
baby you want to go on your country come
on fish fish don't show your goodies oh
yeah show your good sides nice nice
all right he graced us with his presents
too so
now let's go ahead and get into stains
i was gonna actually zoom in here a
little
but i'll just bring a laptop closer that
seems to be the best
solution at the time all right
let's go ahead and give some love to
stains and
i am monitoring the chat closely so
please
feel free to share your thoughts and
comments if you just want to chat
let me know
as i would my um
because i'm pretty sure you're going to
hear people's ears all right
i'm going to go on your couch
so i got the cat to sit down which year
was this game played oh that is a great
question um this one was 18
760 67. yeah this one was 1867.
but uh-uh you're not allowed to eat
anything
[Music]
sorry sick cat not really sure how to
handle it so if you guys have any
suggestions please do let me know
the most has ever had was a little
sniffles
okay so uh this one yeah 18
oh this is so hilarious for me watching
games from
1867. okay let's go ahead and start rock
and rolling
so um this one is very very similar at
least in the opening
to the one that he played with anderson
and that one was amazing i'll try to
have the link
set and the link that we had in
twitch sent in the chat here towards the
end of the class or anybody who want to
go watch that too
also also per usual remember that in an
hour
we are going to switch to twitch and
analyze your games
so if you are playing some chats while
you're having me in the background
listening
feel free to save those and uh load them
on to leachates have the link ready
to send them to me and if you have any
older games that you want to share
that's perfect fine perfectly fine too
so just make sure to have those ready
and
okay so
um any
any suggestions so far
any concerns the one thing that i did
want to mention was
i mean i i play this as black myself so
i don't really see
any issues with it but i think this
knight c6 is very interesting because
a lot of people play knight there's not
a lot of people playing either six with
the suggestion of trying to play d5 like
if f4 now
then you're gonna have d5 so that's one
thing to keep in mind you can bounce
between these two ideas
getting the knights from c6 or f6 um
the one thing that i think is more
recent i mean i think
well yeah almost 10 years ago um
early 2010 to 2014 there was a lot of
this g3 being played with knight c3 then
g3
so keep that in mind too it was very
popular when i played
lower rated chinese opponents or
azerbaijani yeah those two countries
loved everything
hey buddy what's up so yeah we got a lot
of different suggestions like these
going but
anyways this game is 1867.
so there are no real you know there are
no computers if there were that would um
raise some questions
okay so first things first now that we
are on the check we got to get this king
up right g3 is not the way to go
just takes it and that's not a pretty
sign you can't take back
or spelling there's not much else here
so you got to do this king e2
now uh newman
played d6 now what do you think white
should do
also we're gonna take a quick look into
d5 and
analyze why d5 exactly isn't the best
way
greeting from chile thank you
everything's from saint louis
so what do you think between d6 or d5
any suggestions
because here is kind of a critical
position for
black black has to be able to make good
decisions
um yeah do i think the curtain was
stronger than stannis
no i think they were very very close in
the level
in another life zukertort could easily
be the world champion and saying this
could be
like what the zuckerjur's position
but
oh in new jersey i've never i've been to
new york once or twice but very briefly
mainly lego version so i'm gonna mention
d5 a little bit first d5 we kind of
gotta take it
now black has a bunch of suggestions
first bishop g4
the other one if not bishop g4
could be something like just go back and
give check
or even if not that even if you don't
want to
give that check i think those two are
kind of the
um best ones i don't think anything like
96 might be too
um too hopeful because you can't drop
the knife so you kind of have to give a
check
uh let's go back after d5 we gotta take
it
let's just take a look at bishop g4
first knight f3 is kind of forced
castle and now
can we take that what do you think about
this position here
oh no i saw that comment it's okay he
attracted it but i saw it
g4 is doable then that's what we're
doing here too
but my question right now is so black
just sacrificed this knight
is this actually a sacrifice or is it a
blunder
oops
i should have taken the queen i mean i
want to
but right now it's illegal
so taking here is the best choice i
think taking
over here and not accepting is also kind
of interesting
but taking is ultimately the best
fighting chance for white and
then you're eventually going to get
yourself into this
very weird position you got to defend
your d4
and you have this really really weird
king d3
when i was looking at this game i just
thought okay so can i just do c3
and if check then kingly three and then
check then i'll just
you know run with the king and this is
just
way way too scary for my taste
and yeah i am going to
i thought this would be a cool uh
position to actually
give it a second and ask what do you
think white should do
white has this one move that would
potentially
save it a little bit so what do you
think that one move is
okay okay ah this is so much fun
you can't really do this because
checkmate is coming up
it's checkmated two moves does anybody
want to tell me where is the check my
team 2 moves
it is crazy game and this is not what
happened in the game the game was
quite crazy but this would have been
like a little better fighting chance for
black
and yes this is my living room
hi
exactly 94 and check my ideas
in the dimple yeah i'm thinking
potentially i guess my d7 also works too
but that's just the easier way with
knight e4
so we can't just do that there is white
has one
single move to survive this if you can
call that surviving actually
what do you think that one move is
running around
yeah i don't know what's wrong with him
he's um he's not more like
fine but at the same time like
i think his spirit and physically
everything is fine just when he um
his stomach bothers him a little but i
don't i didn't even know this because
he's not really
you know making any noises like that
uh bishop c4 okay i see that you're
trying to stop it but still check
and then just bishop d7
and even check mate click on or i can
just take here and check mate
so the problem is this pawn is taking
over squares
this knight is kind of uh blocking your
king
so what do you think
knight c7 exactly let's get rid of that
and if you check then you try to block
it but this is like a really crazy line
that's like that kind of the only way
for white to continue and hold some uh
counter play but you can see it's super
super duper crazy you could even like
take that first
if you take it back then i can take this
and
this is wrong this is going on it is
such a crazy game
all right so yeah that's kind of why
it's best fighting chance
let's go back back back
and even more back so we got
from here we were like c3 was
interesting but then they were like man
what about king d3
now i kind of avoided the c3 now i want
to eat
whoa i want to eat your queen and if
like something like queen h5
now instead of doing c3 that i get
checked that my king has to go up
how can i try to find a somewhat safe
position with the
for the king
hey
that would be my lipstick that he just
threw down
oh this is playful
okay what do we think here
let's say we did this good thing and we
need to put our king into a safe corner
yep king c3 lovely thank you everybody
yeah
king c3 and now uh taking is not exactly
the best
choice because we just take back and we
run
and a block because we have to extra
material we
we have the luxury of giving some of it
back
and this kind of holds the position
still very scary but it holds and white
ends up winning
so let's say not bishop d4 what do you
think
is the best move for white you have any
suggestions gmp she
no no resigning we're not gonna resign
what do anything is the best move for
black right now remember
this knight here defending the pawn this
knight is kind of still a little
uh you know under pressure
asics thank you almost yep
well that's the bad one a6 kick this guy
away
if you can't exactly move it just around
because first of all
uh this check exists and then you have
to move the king and then you can eat or
here or something even queen d5
yeah centralizing the queen then i want
to just do knights e4 a lot of
a lot of good stuff are happening for
white
tour black sorry so a6 you can't exactly
move this so what can you do
so we can't move this knight so we're
gonna have to lose it
bishop f4 i don't really get that
because especially because of this check
and take
we could do baby king b3
with that idea but then takes over here
so that also doesn't exactly work
any suggestions no what about maybe
trying to or get this king to you know
go to this a little safe place
how about that
i kind of like this idea trying to you
know push over here i want to eat it i
want to do king b2
uh if you try to run away then i could
try
to um
oh i like this h3 that's being suggested
in the chat too honestly
hey maybe maybe why not this three i
want to eat pieces
if you take it i'll take it back
if take then king b3
if you don't move it if you take it well
great i'll just take it over here and my
king is
uh have a little safe spot these pawns
are protecting it i like it
is this bunk cloud opening not exactly
it started as vienna and then it kind of
um
made its way into some really crazy
stuff all right so let's go back i don't
want the little limb
tired of looking at crazy stuff
so let's go all the way back
actually let's do this queen e7
now what do we do we gotta move the king
right you can't really exactly stop it
so let's do the king of f2 you give
check
now the big question is
should we repeat or should we do g3
yeah yeah g3 i agree
now if take now we can do king g2 see
that's the cool stuff
now after king g2 black has
some interesting choices one of them
bishop d6
one of them free pawn let's see what
else can we think of
i think those two maybe knight f6 could
also be interesting
but the problem with knight f6 simply is
i'll just take it over here you don't
really have any checks to follow
so let's go back to king g2
uh no knight f6 let's take a quick look
at knight d4
if knight d4 i'm gonna take it over here
attack your
queen queen moves now should we exchange
or should we give check
what do you think
okay
oh look who's talking now
all right okay so i'm seeing a lot of
great comments in the chat thank you
thank you i agree let's keep the queen
good choice
if we were to exchange it it's okay but
their big problem is this pawn i can't
exactly just
uh continue developing because
my you know this knight can't really
move their especially with three and i'm
having a har i'm gonna have a hard time
kicking this knight away and the pieces
aren't much active
yeah black would have an easier
development
oh uh i wouldn't exactly gain the tempo
because there would always be h5s too
rt and
uh oh satrange
that sounds like shots range which in
varsity means chess
anywho i like queen e1 you
lock it i just develop then defend
you move away careful now the potential
of racket 4
is also there now you move it now i just
developed i think bishop f4 was also
cool too
yeah we are doing king safety right now
my king is fine
that's kind of the fun part because your
queen is so out there and my pieces are
just developing because i get the chance
to actually develop
this position is winning for a light
even if black tries that's fine that's
okay
i can't even do cool stuff like this
right
yeah this was actually quite funny
because this was a game that zuckertort
played
and he won needless to say
all right so it's very very cool
suggestion
very cool idea and it's not that after
queenie won
white's the winning it's that this king
has to go to f8 and this king has to
stay around
here so then let's say you would play
like bishop f4 and then something like
bishop
f5 would be fine or something like h5
this king has to stay around here
because when you long castle you don't
have enough pieces to cover your king up
and so it's kind of that
same thing oh uh am i saying it correct
uh sad saturn or
c i know sometimes it's really is um red
as
j could be i don't know if the s
is c so
fun stuff i'm learning how to read a
little
okay so let's go back to um
better days for black let's do know
knight before let's do hi
bb let's do bishop d6
you wanna join the class or you just
wanna hug
what do you want
that works too
so what now
oh thank you i love him too he's a good
baby
yeah knight f3 is fun
no knight f3 bishop h3 not checklist but
it is kind of scary i agree
you gotta move it and then black
definitely does have considerable
advantage
to say the least okay so not mine f3
so bishop d6 you can see that is
stopping you from eating
this pond you know checkmate haha
um so can i eat over here
that's another question facil i am not a
medical student
yet i am studying to do the entrance and
exam 2 starts next year
but the way that stakes studying for
exam is going oh
god it's never going to end
pin i like that but can i eat that is
that for free
the only thing that we should be
concerned is take right
because i can't exactly do that now i'll
get
the variety of checkmated
exactly now i would have to do something
like queen f3
you take here i take that and then
this is okay this is playable
um the potential for
queenie one what do we think oh i got a
cough
sorry it's a very eventful day with
the cats
uh am i visiting us no i have a green
card and i intend to live here for
the rest of my days i mean i
like the option of europe if i'm ever
rich enough vacation houses in every
state and just you know
travel around but no i
intend to live in u.s
yeah i like this queen you want to if
something like you try to develop and
cut it i can now eat it
no more problems here yeah i think this
would be
what's best way to continue and this is
so we got so far off from the main line
from the actual game
and i think it was worth it because this
is actually a very
crucial position here literally move
five
so d6 the rest of the game is not as
crazy in depth line we kind of
already looked at over half of the
analysis that i had for this game
so you're good we're not we're not uh in
any trouble
there is a cute kitty thing here who
might want to join our class sometime
but
yeah i have to do a little research on
upset cat's stomach
poor guy
all right so
one thing that we should be cautious of
is bishop g4 that's actually
newman uh in this game also played now
we eat this for free
take and now we kind of have to take it
to the king
careful if you take it the pawn you drop
this poor guy
and you could go for a knight d5 and
then take over here and stuff but this
would give black the upper hand
so it's best to just take it to the king
and that is why i'm showing you this
game
because it's such a crazy game now if my
top six what do you think black or white
should do
any suggestions gnpc want to come
tell the viewers what to do if you have
not seen that quick
cute little clip of gmp ships making
suggestion moves
you should
hello steve what's up oh i got cat hair
everywhere man oh god
oh
um yeah i like g3 i also think bishop
e5 is worth considering
and if you cast out i can just take it
over here and then do queen d3 go after
those
goodies
yeah i think that would be interesting
um but
i also think g3 is definitely worth it
if you try to check
just king g2 king is safe yeah
either of these now what about knight e7
oh my
sorry that probably was my bad i was
trying to lower the volume so when i
cough your ears won't be
tickled
any suggestions i kind of like this g3
idea i think it could work again here
too
but i also really want to get this
bishop out so maybe let's start with a
bishop
is this a puzzle not exactly this
is a game that was played in 1876
this is shannon's game shane is playing
this game against
newman and so we're kind of analyzing
that game and we're kind of pausing
to get some suggestions from you guys
yeah i agree let's try to develop i
think bishop v2 is interesting but
i still do think that
the idea with g3 is very safe too if you
want to continue that you just have to
be careful because
of the weaknesses that your position has
so this should be too much better yeah
now what chad what should what do you
think black's gonna do after bishop e2
yeah we can try to get the saber king i
think long castle
is a good idea but i also think that the
similar idea
to try to go after d4 and f4 at the same
time
does work so if black wanted to try that
that would be a valid choice too
now newman just went for
long castle now bishop e3 was played in
the game i think
now maybe g3 would have still been a
fine choice
or tried to d5 it but
a kind of earned the landed in this
suggestion with bishop e3 and
makes sense too
um i am
incapable of reading that
turk english turkish
if it was english farsi slash english i
could read that
so bishop e3 check now king g3
now black did d5 now i want to know what
do you think white should do and a
potential evaluation who would you want
to be
this is not a very long game white
actually won this
in about 20
moves 20 more moves
so it's not bad
where can you get puzzles um
uh well a lot of these puzzles a lot of
the
lessons that i teach i also shared the
leeches link for the puzzles
related to them so there's a bunch of
them on leachates that's
uh understand loose chess club
okay white definitely does have a more
interesting
the who definitely i mean this king is
way more interesting than that king
but uh we're not exactly looking for the
in
interesting contest
so the position is kind of balanced
yeah white does have a little bit of
spatial advantage potentially powerful
bishop pair
but at the moment we have to kind of
figure out what to do with the king and
we have to try and put
it behind the pawns before we can do any
serious
stuff yeah black
king is pretty solid um and black is
doing stuff in the center
trying to
open up the center and go after white's
king yeah
so it's kind of a roughly balanced i
want to say but honestly right now i
would want to be black
bishop g4 king b8 e5 okay
queen g6 so far i like all of these
knight f5 is possible too but just take
take and that's not exactly the ideal
situation that we find ourselves in
that king f2 what do we think about king
f2
good bad needed not needed too extra
yeah so i think once trying to do that
artificial castling with my king f2
move the row potentially king g1
yeah i'm probably thinking ab2 is good
enough i think queen d3 is worth
considering two but
take take and h5 this bishop is getting
really tickled because they have to be
careful knight f5 also exists and then
g5
and stuff's happening i don't really
like what's happening ah
yeah it's really scary all right let's
go back
so king f2 and now what
let's say h5 attacking the bishop bishop
moves now
black still wants to continue to open up
the
center slash king side so f6
take take and queen f3 now
queen f3 yes no do we need it do we not
need it
oh naka also says tickled now recently i
i've been working so hard my whole life
i know i'm not ticklish but i got
tickled
and i actually laughed and i was i
actually felt ticklish and then later on
i felt bruised a little
but still
yep it is necessary i agree something
like king g1
is just a little too cringy honestly
all right so queen f3 take take and
finally uh keep in mind taking with the
king
still g5 makes this position still
a little questionable for white so we
don't want to do that we don't want to
give our opponent chances to
get all happy so we take with pond keep
the bishop here
leave a little little room for the
breathing and we have an extra pond
sorry we don't have an extra pond we
have this extra
pair of bishops so let's try to use them
yeah so g6 let's try to
bring more pressure to the side that
they actually can do something with
you remember my bishop is put taking
control over um
this diagonal and here black actually
made a mistake which is i'm a little
still not sure why black did this black
played knight at five why do you think
knight had five is a mistake
because so far black has played really
good and he had
at least equal position so
what now why do you think like how can
what's going on basically
my laptop is being very loud
hopefully it's not bothering you guys
yep yeah exactly we kind of just get the
chance to take it over here
and the best way for
black to play this instead of knight
coming to f5
was to play something like bishop g7
and maybe something like activate this
bishop from here
and yeah i think that would be the most
uh interesting way for black to go about
it
but knight f5 and black kind of made a
mistake
white got a little advantage out of it
now
we it's so weird
um we started this game
as like super crazy my king was all the
way on like
f3 and then we ended up looking at the
lines where the king could end up on
c5 or like in a good way on like c3 so
like we
looked at this king flying king oh maybe
that should be the title of this
lesson flying king yeah um if you looked
at this like flying
king and now we landed on like this
kind of normal end game so i'm like whoa
what the heck happened here
all right so
what do you think white's trying to
achieve
um almost that is partially true
there has uh this like provoking uh
to get the exchange done is a great idea
but no
i mean that bishop on h3 was not doing
anything you could just let it sit
yeah see the thing is that black has
been a little hopeless right now
why you ask because after this d3 the
night is misplaced the knight is not
doing anything here
and let's say black tries to be all cute
about it develops
okay fine let's exchange
and you have these very big pawns and i
get to win the
um open file and that's why
it doesn't really work anymore for you
yep black thought he was doing well yeah
yeah that knight f5 was a terrible
mistake now
black can just cook i mean blackheads
try to activate the pieces but that
doesn't matter
we're just gonna push this king away and
even more now what do you think white
should do
okay i see a retracted message why
don't distract your messages let me read
them
no no no no no yeah retract that no
no too early you have kind of the right
idea that you want to
um get your pieces
to find like do that final below but
your pieces are not ready your drugs are
not ready
let me ask you could your knight be
improved i think
also h4 is a good idea but
um what about your knight what child
that poor knights do
thank you mj tyree that's very nice of
you
yeah they're i'm so glad they managed to
um keep educating
throughout the last day last year this
year and we're
we're getting some new uh directions on
how to try open safely for
more people so quite excited about that
but
honestly one of the things that i'm very
excited about for
this year except getting rid of mcat
is that the club is doing expansions
so i'm like very like this is something
that's i've been hearing about for like
years now
so i'm really excited to see how it's
going to play out like i know that
um the club has been working on like uh
like they
got on the the new like the block of it
and like i saw i've seen the plans the
blueprint but not the
extra blueprint like the video uh
blueprint of it and i'm
so just like so excited i just i really
hope
that there are um opening soon the
constructions are done
i've been fully vaccinated i want to go
out well actually technically i want to
go out to the club but not that type of
club i want to go to the chess club
this should be a meme why are you
getting masturbated to go to the club
the chess club
oh god all right so i'm gonna stop being
uh a little weird and
yeah oh yeah of course gotham stress is
really great
i'm so glad for everything that the
streamers have done throughout
last year to bring popularity to chess
and with the queen's gambit it's just
like chess got everywhere man
all right yeah knight d3 thank you
almost i saw that earlier as something
sorry i took a little while yeah knight
d3 knight e5
is the best way now when the knight gets
to e5
honestly here b3 is just like you want
to eat my pawn uh-uh
not happening but when the knight gets
to e5 this rook f7
is like the killer idea
also this knight's jumping to d7 is
another
so the rook tries to go okay let's keep
cooking the stroke
now what do you think we should do now
we are like three moves out from winning
what do you think is the way
to be completely fair there are multiple
ways of winning this
or fixtures from gmp
oh
move the king interesting
why would i move the king as white as
white i want to try to
somehow get get you like few checks and
get my pieces in there and
i think something like rook f7 under
rook g7 is also very cool
i think actually rook f7 rook g7 might
be the
fastest slash easiest way to win you
move this and then i'll just bring it to
the other side
yeah i think this could actually be the
easiest way to win
but anyways uh status wanted to be
trickier and fancier
than me so he went for b4 and
after drake a6 now let's see what's what
do you think white should do if
rook takes a4
oh
exactly d7 check king moves knight c5
give me that truck same thing cap
actually happened in the game with the
difference that drook went to a6
and after knight d7 this is still
super duper winning i
multiple ways of actually winning this
one of it is just b5
trying to trap the rook if you try to
move hello if you try to go over here
then i can just bring this rook over
try to go that way or i can just be like
you know what i just want to eat this
this is like what
plus 10 8 whatever this is like super
winning too
so uh not that let's go back
yeah that was kind of the big game that
i wanted to show you now
i'm going to share i can't actually
share the link with you
um let me see maybe i could type the
link in here
bleachers.org
let's do that study
let's do that so
all right you guys try to see if this
link works
because hopefully this when this link
does work and
you will have access to this game
and uh some of the previous like the
the game that i did right before this
game was
i did this on sunday so it's the
uh game is also on twitch analysis feel
free to go look that up too it's the
game between stainless and anderson
it was such a cool game i'll just give
you a little
spoiler what
[Music]
all right so uh feel free to check that
out too there are other puzzles in this
study
if you can open it let me know
um and
yeah so we're gonna take a short break
um and we are doing your
uh segments of switched twitch i'll see
you
on twitch in about 10 minutes please
have your games ready
in leeches format so
um yeah ideally you can send me your
games
which is linked to a game on leeches
with lovely chess so have that we're
gonna have a lot of fun with it
okay so i will see you guys in about 10
minutes
don't forget to have some games for me
and if you have to go
thank you for being here i'll see you